[Musique]
les gens qui ne pensent pas trop ne
savent pas l'effet que ça fait d'être
tout le temps plongé dans ses pensées
voir le motiver l'oms qui tourne tourne
tourne qui tournait 14 mai mais ceux qui
souffrent de rumination une chose de
rumination pour faire simple en gros dés
des idées négatives qui luttent partir
rester à ce désastre savent bien
l'énergie mentale qu'il faut la fatigue
que cela crée et ses rares moments en en
vacances de soi même ou marque de penser
mais on se sent bien pensé c'est quelque
chose d'épuisants évidemment pas quand
il s'agit de deux pensées positives de
pensée créative de de rêverie ça va
c'est beaucoup plus que plus que ça
c'est très agréable mais quand il s'agit
de pensées négatives d'inquiétude de
manière contrôlée de penser au futur
c'est très très très fatigant et et
cette séance d'hypnose vous permettre
justement d'arrêter toutes vos pensées
pour laisser la place à a davantage
d'idées positive à davantage de rêverie
aussi pour que vous soyez
globalement dans une dimension plus
plus confiante et ça passe vraiment
d'abord par les ruminations pour moi le
manque de confiance en soi c'est ça
c'est au lieu de parler à quelqu'un de
faire quelque chose c'est de ce top
servette se critiquer alors tout de
suite quand on pense moins évidemment on
souffre au moindre manque de confiance
en soi c'est presque mathématique
alors aujourd'hui on a fait un séance
d'hypnose pour travailler là-dessus
travail se fait arrêter de penser était
bien positiver dans une démarche plus
confiante
vous pourrez retrouver des séances
d'hypnose gratuite en mp3 sur le site
city un coach point fr des articles
surtout les différents sujets qui sont
abordés dans ces vidéos et vous abonner
également ma chaîne youtube se cache
eyecode chine et surtout surtout aller
sur le site du figaro live puisque
actuellement nous sommes en train de
bâtir toute une collection de vidéos
d'hypnose pour vous permettre d'être
mieux au quotidien c'est ça la grande
ligne directrice et le quotidien c'est
ce c'est permettre de mieux dormir
davantage concentré de se reposer
davantage de ne pas souffrir d'être de
mieux mémoriser et c'était vraiment des
choses qui sont très très
pratiquez vous pourrez utiliser comme ça
et vous en avez besoin
l'idéal étant malgré tout de faire
régulièrement parce que l'action est
encore plus efficace alors sur cette
séance d'hypnose par été pensé en
particulier s'il peut faire bien tous
les jours si possible en début de
journée pour vous profitez puis si vous
n'avez pas le temps m'a tant pis vous
faites un autre moment mais essayer de
viser une vraie bonne régularité pour en
maximiser les effets ne pas le faire une
seule fois et arrêter ça se passait un
test permettra juste de warcq ça marche
mais pas dans d'en tester l'efficacité
globalement et d'avoir un effet plus
important viser vraiment la régularité
puis pour le reste vous n'avez
absolument qu'un effort à fournir
vous pouvez vous asseoir vous allongez
trouver une posture qui vous convienne
et puis essayer simplement évidemment
pendant cette séance déranger mais même
si ça devait arriver ça n'a pas grande
importance si vous invitez a commencé à
fixer un point 1 points le bo j'ai peu
importe déjà si vous faites vraiment
avec attention ces principes de la
méditation pleine conscience
vous serez déjà moins dans les
ruminations faut le faire également un
pack votre respiration est ce que vous
observerez aussi et qui est assez
amusant c'est que si vous regardez au
dessus de votre ligne de regard nous
aurait beaucoup moins de facilité à
visualiser les choses et donc vous aurez
tendance à moins ruminer n'hésitez pas à
en faire l'essai quand vous êtes
un moment vous ruminez particulièrement
vous posez vous regarder quelque chose
et vous essayez de le regarder au dessus
de votre ligne de regard et vous verrez
que le flot de pensées sera moins
important alors commencé à à fixer un
point donc un peu au dessus d'autres
lignes des regards et le regarder avec
un regard doux on dira jamais assez à
quel point plus corps et détendue et
l'esprit l'est également pour qui rien
que ce regard doux
cette focalisation sur ce point c'est un
début
emma voir enfin le reste du travail et
ce qui est formidable à clip no c'est
que pour une fois vous allez pouvoir
vous laisser porter et vous qu'il y
avait peut-être peu plus tôt
rassemblement'' tendance à trop penser
ce n'est absolument pas grave si à
certains moments où décroché au
contraire et ça ne dérange pas si un
certain moment certaines pensées
parasites vous revenir de toute façon au
début quand on pratique l'hypnose ya
toujours cette auto observations un
petit côté critique que tout à fait
normale et très bien et au fur et à
mesure que la séance va progresser lieu
ses pensées vont disparaître mais là
tout le temps pour le confort n'est pas
d'effort à faire tout le travail est
pour moi prenez une
une posture qui soit confortable pour
vous moi qui suis assise par exemple tu
peux détendre simplement mais c'est paul
un peu les muscles de mon visage
d'installer un peu plus confortablement
sur le dossier de la chaise vous trouvez
votre posture de confort ce sera la
faute
ce sera très bien
et cette séance est enregistré avec un
son binaural à 360° donc coupé
m'entendre d'une oreille puis de l'autre
cela permet d'avoir une expérience
davantage immersive de décrocher aussi
plus rapidement
je vais compter de 5 à 1
peu importe le moment où vous arrêterez
de penser cela arrivera peut-être
rapidement cela prendra peut-être un peu
plus de temps ça n'a pas d'importance
vous écoutez ma voix vous pouvez
observer déjà un niveau inconscient et
changements subtils simplement le fait
d'écouter consciemment à voir se poser
confortablement n'a pas tant qu'on soit
dédié au bien-être et déjà une sorte de
processus d'intériorisation se met en
place des différentes
ce mécanisme quand on est enfermé dans
ses pensées dans quelque chose de plus
tout n'est que le début et déjà vous
pouvez ressentir davantage les
sensations du corps
le contact de l'air contre le visage
contact de l'air contre l'om
quand on pense trop on est comme dans
une sorte de bulle se dissocie des
sensations du corps se dissocie des
choses autour de nous et c'est comme si
on vous baigner dans ses pensées comme
si elle tournait autour de nous et tout
ce qui permet de sortir de cette bulle
ils vont apprendre à voir qui va faire
sortir de cette bulle pour aller vers
les transvaal hypnose notre respiration
qui va devenir de plus en plus calmes et
12 servir de support à votre
concentration et à votre voyage vers
l'inconscient par l'hypnose et parfois
il suffit de ralentir pour m'imposer de
se poser de regarder de respirer plus
lentement
juste un premier pas et c'est exactement
ce que la méditation plus de l'hypnose
vous invite à faire à prendre votre
temps à se centrer sur l'instant présent
dans un esprit de pleine conscience et
en faisons tous cas déjà et bien en
place ce processus d'intériorisation la
respiration qui devient grand plus lente
et surtout plus régulière et puis comme
nous était monsieur là les mêmes lots
pensées sont ralliés à la respiration
observerez que plus vous pensez que
l'autre respiration et courtes et
rapides
et dès que la tempête de votre calme
sais-tu la respiration est aussi se
ralentit peut-être est-ce la respiration
qui ralentit qui atténue les pensées ou
peut-être les deux ensembles et votre
respiration et votre esprit deviennent
de plus en plus calmes et pour
accompagner et accélérer cette évolution
je l'invité à prendre deux inspirations
profondes
comme cela et après votre respiration va
pouvoir s'approfondir tout seul il n'y a
pas d'efforts à faire non seulement
écouter la voix hier que les pensées
s'accroche décroche déjà dans un jeu
dans les pensées un peu différente dans
des pensées négatives et positives aussi
davantage entremêlées - fixe + mobile
plus légères alors que vous pensez se
forment se déforme forme d'autres formes
et déjà se laisse porter par le courant
d hypnose cette respiration devient plus
profonde de gamme plantes et vous pouvez
sentir cam devrait inspirer sentir de
quelle manière il se diffuse dans les
poumons comme des racines de cannes
sentir comment progressivement tout le
corps se détend pas de plus en plus en
transe plus impliqué
c'est très rare
toujours au point car
cadres et d'autres sensations pour
s'installer comme le poids de la
respiration un peu plus lourde
un peu plus lente peu plus régulier
aussi une sorte de poids au niveau des
pensées comme si elle avancé un peu plus
lentement tout cas que pensée consciente
ou s'ils perdaient de leur énergie de
leur vivacité alors que le corps et la
détente se gagne en énergie enfants et
le corps devient le lieu est un peu plus
lourd emploi des bras pour allégeant le
poids de tout le corps sympa aussi
tout comme faisait davantage pour essai
vos pensées inconsciente
votre esprit inconscient plus de
légèreté à vos pensées consciente un peu
plus de lourdeur pour qu'elle puisse au
fur et à mesure de leur pesanteur et de
la lenteur disparaître
l'histoire je vais vous raconter dans un
instant que je raconte de séance en
séance toujours au début pour aider à
entrer en transe
une des nombreuses manières de décrocher
tu arrêter de penser il s'agit de ce que
l'on appelle une mise en abyme wind mise
en abyme très agréable évidemment
puisqu'il s'agit du meneur et vous allez
voir que c'est naturellement décroche se
raccrocher à davantage de cas alors
imaginez ressentez le poids du corps
lourd qui laisse l'esprit s'alléger ce
corps qui alourdit j'ai un fauteuil un
lien canet lourdement posé sur le sol
sol lourdement posées sur les fondations
de cet immeuble de sept maisons des
fondations celui manqué sur la ville
mais ville
une encre et jetable santé comme on
oublie de penser la terre seulement
ancré dans le système solaire le système
solaire ancré dans la galaxie la galaxie
solidement ancrée dans l'univers
l'univers solidement ancré dans le temps
et le temps ce mouvement en créant vous
disent que vous en crée de plus en plus
intense bien ce propos la transe et un
état où l'on pense beaucoup moins je
n'ai pas un état où on ne pense plus mr
l'état mais pensée consciente donc à
main peu en cours dit et comme toujours
nous serait centrée sur quelque chose
m'avoir le temps qui semble passer
différemment les sensations des
expériences
que vous vivez au fur et à mesure de la
séance d'hypnose et 12 éloignerait
mécaniquement dépensé imaginé et vivre
pour moi penser c'est le secret 3
alors que dépenser s'accroche se
décrochent donc faire ce faisant ce
faire rien tout ce que l'on sait fait
leur vie en tête cette histoire
l'histoire de ces deux promeneurs l'un
qui vont c'est trop et là qu'ils ne
pensaient pas assez il se promenait dans
la forêt l'un occupé par ses pensées
essayer de contrôler des choses
incontrôlables de se souvenir de détail
signé tine d'envisager plein de
situations auxquelles finalement il ne
pourra que improvisé où trouver des
solutions plus tard et l'autre dans la
tranquillité de son esprit s'oublier lui
même et devenait tantôt l'arbre le
papillon
toussaint pesant directement et
totalement à son esprit connaissez cette
devise heureux les simples d'esprit bien
c'est certainement cours de cette balade
à quillan résultats alors que celui qui
ne pensaient pas assez vais vraiment
vécu cette expérience l'aude qui pensait
trop devait finalement été que dans ses
pensées
si le plus de cette histoire n'est pas
du préconisé de ne jamais penser de
louer l'absence de pensée c'est en
revanche une invitation à savoir varier
savoir faire évoluer son niveau de
penser à pouvoir passer la pensée la
plus profonde la sensation de
l'extérieur est plus vive à pouvoir
cumuler ces deux qualités celle de pau
va être contemplatif sans pensée celle
de pouvoir penser avec force et avec
intelligence de savoir trouver le juste
milieu qui fait que nous profite à la
fois des deux est de ceux que la vie des
pentes et de ce que le monde dépensés
pour construire 2 alors que vous pensez
s'accroche se décrochent s'accroche
c'est d'écran d'un permanence au pas
maman conjugaison
redéfinition de soi dans la pensée de la
pensée qui se penser dans la sensation
d'un sensations qui se ressent un mais
se fermer sept centres ans une tranche
de l'agréable
et comme pour toutes les personnes qui
pensent trop et transmettre en place
progressivement de fois en fois c'est
pour ça que c'est bien utiliser cette
séance tous les jours pour apprendre est
dans un état différent - quand c'est
pour permettre de consolider cet
apprentissage vous allez faire dans
cette séance d'hypnose et dans d'autres
aussi qu'on trouverait tu les différents
sites
bien plus bien tous les jours pour
apprendre à votre esprit
ce que c'est que de ne pas avancer
ressentir vous êtes maintenant en transe
il ya plein de techniques de
communication dans l'hypnose qui
participe aux fêtes d'arrêter de penser
pour rentrer dans cet état inconscient
kylie minogue et à cet accompagnement
progressive que vous sentez à voix vous
accompagne de l'état dans lequel vous
étiez tout à l'heure vers l'état dans
lequel vous serez bientôt
mais il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle les
techniques de confusion de manière
simplement de parler pour faire perdre
un peu le fil pour fatiguer l'esprit et
vous verrez en dehors de cette séance
c'est un moment il vous suffira de vous
rappeler certaines de ses paroles de la
confusion quelqu'un confusion
récupérables c'est à dire simplement
l'impression de décrocher voix a été
devancée
peut-être qu'à certains moments vous
entendrez cette race vos pensées
s'accroche et ses décors et peut-être
certaines fois penserez-vous à cette
phrase faire et ce faisant de ce fait
renaître rien d'autre que ce que l'on
sait faire
cette phrase que j'ai emprunté à sartre
mais qui en elle même porte des graines
agréable de confusion dans cette idée là
conclusion dans la manière dont
le secret de mon esprit car l'esprit
conscient de percevoir que c'est plus ou
moins deux choses en même temps dans
cette conjugaison de ce qu'elle apporte
cette sorte de médiation entre l'esprit
conscient d'esprit inconscient la
manière car finalement d'oreilles ont
cependant de percevoir dans ses moindres
nuances dans ses moindres variations et
le ton et le sens et parfois même la
symbolique dans un niveau
conscient qu inconscient dans cette
manière de se dire de se voir finalement
recréer en soi un monde intérieur d'être
pas comme un filtre déformant mais comme
une sorte de prisme par lequel on
regarde certaines personnes parlent de
caunes de perception c'est peut-être
dans cet entre deux dans cette
variabilité dans cette simplification
comme une sorte d'aller retour entre
inconscient beau conscient le conscient
et l'inconscient son parrain de cet état
autres qu'est le pré conscient ce moment
où les pensées inconsciente à fleurs la
conscience pour devenir consciente elle
aussi au parfois retournent directement
la conscience
cette image jolie que la représentation
de l'esprit inconscient un iceberg avec
évidemment le conscients qu'ils
représentaient à la partie émergée
l'inconscient la partie submergée ou
peut être est ce une simplification
entre ceux qui pensent qu'il ya des
instances de contrôle sur moi et
d'autres personnes comme moi qui
considère que l'inconscient avait
quelque chose qui veille à notre
sécurité et qui nous pousse vers notre
bonheur souvent avec maladresse et au
mieux de ce qu'il veut faire
les situations c'est dans cette
définition même de ce qu'est
l'inconscient et il n'y a jamais un
chemin pour aller à un objectif
tous les chemins sont bon du moment
qu'ils vous correspondent
dès qu'ils se dirigent vers cet objectif
tu me manques inconsciemment c'est vous
allez du moment qu'on prend le temps de
savourer la vie dans ce qu'elle peut
apporter comme si la vie devait durer
l'éternité un jour reprendre ce si joli
titre de vie ce si beau fils ou
d'ailleurs
et dans cette perception dans ce type de
ressenti cette manière plus gai ou la
transe qui prend le nom d'hypnose ou qui
donne à son nom et à sa représentation
ce que l'hypnose peur lui apportèrent
les mêmes dans toutes ces similitudes
ces ressemblances et même parfois temps
c'est différent
cette manière aussi que l'on a parfois
dans les pensées l'interrompre ou
d'intervertir les causes les
conséquences de chercher du sens là où
il y en a pas de se poser des questions
inutiles chose est bien une chose
nécessaire c'est de se demander non pas
6 me débats de mauvaises non pas un
sunnite et est positive ou négative mais
simplement de se demander est ce une
idée était dante limitantes de faire des
poupées en soit les pensées qui nous
savent nous rendent heureux plutôt
qu'uniquement les pensées d'une vérité
qui ne s'adapteraient pas à la réalité
de vie d'une vérité aussi appartenant au
passé dépassé par nos expériences nous
changeons toujours nous évoluons
toujours de nous toujours ce que nous
n'étions plus de le dire et seront
peut-être parce que nous sommes
ce krach poser cette question très
intéressante si vous aviez le choix
entre être un socrate malheureux ou un
pourceau heureux que vous choisiriez
vous tuerez tendance à choisir pour se
re met finalement pourquoi choisir
pourquoi n'aurait-on pas le droit d'être
un socrate heureux ou quand la pensée de
modèle
sa compagne est forcément de souffrance
qui a dit que souffrir tu es intelligent
qui a dit qu'être intelligent sait
souffrir pouvait être intelligent et
heureux ou être intelligent et parfois
et même souvent de ma pensée vous pouvez
le droit art responsabilité de
l'intelligence la créativité vous avez
le droit de reprise et vous avez le
droit de lâcher prise et le droit de
vivre ces droits de vie plutôt que de
toujours penser vous alors à de penser
évidemment quand vous dépensez vous avez
tous les droits
cela va sans dire pour reprendre ce
slogan de toute façon en pensez en
psychologie est interdit d'interdire
alors vous pensez - vous le sentez vous
pensez déjà beaucoup moi
parce que la transe installant vous de
plus en plus nous avons une convention
l'autre à hypnotique
je vais laisser à votre inconscient
l'appréciation les impressions et les
changements qu une histoire à lui
apporter il s'agit d'une histoire qui se
passe aux mains des rivières où vivent
des assets des hommes essentiellement
qui au travers de la méditation et des
privations de la solitude est aussi
parfois de la fortification douleur
corps vise une sorte de délivrance de
sagesse d'inspiration certainement là
trouve-t-il parfois
c'est l'histoire d'un de se mettre cet
aveu si guy qui a reçu un jour un jeune
dame jeune homme très intelligent très
au fait et des connaissances son temps
et de la religion
un jeune homme érudit peut-être même
plus serré dit que cet ascète se mettra
cents
et ce jeune homme était venu à tirer à
la réputation de sagesse de se mettre à
cinq ou six peut-être par la réputation
qu'il avait de voir certains pouvoirs
parfois on croit chercher la sagesse et
puis on cherche des choses plus triaire
et le mettre à sac le dit installe toi
là juste en face de ce champ paissent
les bulles et jeter accepterait comme
mon apprenti qu'une fois que tu seras
devenir plus intelligent que plus
intelligent que ses buffles le jeune
homme qui pensait déjà tout savoir sur
la vie c'est le propre de la jeunesse
se sont fixés il s'installa en position
de lotus
il regarde il se mit en méditation avec
un zèle hors du commun
et comme il était à côté d'un champ et
ses débuts et que les buffles font leurs
besoins comme tous les animaux de l'état
il y avait des mouches
et sinon tu tournait autour de lui et il
avait beau site matran invitation à
chaque fois se positionner empêchait se
concentrer je sois mort qu'il arrive à
quoi tu m'aides pour lui demander s'il
acceptait comme disciple mettre le dit
tu es plus bête qu'un but plein pourquoi
je t'ai accepta accord mondial tu
essayais de méditer toute cette journée
et pourtant tu vois bien tu n'y as pas
arrivé alors qu'en face c'est ben hur
accepter l accepter c'est un confort et
vaquer à leur vie avec peut-être plus de
sagesse que tu n'auras jamais retourne à
de ce champ mais lorsque tu auras
accepter ces mouches
je n'accepterai comme monde ici
fallu du temps jeu là pour apprendre à
accepter ces mouches
le défi peut sembler dérisoire mais
lorsqu'il revint voir le mettra sept
il avait compris beaucoup de choses
avaient compris que la vie est
désagrément a uniquement bien sûr mais
aussi de désagréments et que comme un
buffle dans un show qui regarde les
choses qui ne se débat pas face à ces
insectes à ceux ci mushi valait mieux
les accepter plutôt que de se battre
contre al parce que l'on se bat contre
une mouche et plus elle vous attend
comme pour les pensées plus vous luttez
plus souvent vendalisé s'agissait de les
accepter d'accepter aussi les choses qui
sont en dehors de notre pouvoir
jamais aucun homme ne pourra se
débarrasser totalement des mouches
jamais aucun homme pourra se débarrasser
de la naure dette nette des impôts sont
des choses fixe qu'il faut accepter à ce
qu'elle est ne faut pas se débattre et
puis finalement accepté que les pensées
les choses la vie se pose sur nous et
repartent telles qu'elles sont arrivées
ce qu'il advint de ce jeune homme ce que
le maître à 7 par la suite lui a pris on
ne sait pas vous plaît certainement
l'imaginé comme j'ai imaginé cette
histoire ont fait revivre à votre
inconscient certaines cités certaines
perceptions symbolique importante est en
tout cas la bande un jour de sa fin le
très trop ce que l'on maîtrise et ce
qu'on ne maîtrise pas j'étais bien
comprendre que le but est d' accepter
que les pensées se pose sur nous comme
des mouches pour repartir comme ceux ci
de là même
jeu pour vous entraîner ainsi que ce
jeune à 7
je vais demander à votre esprit
inconscient de vous faire vivre une
mouche qui représentera une de vos
rumination je vais vous inviter à
ressentir tout en étendant la
tranquillité de transe cette mouche qui
se posent sur vous de futilité voir se
débattre de voir la taper
et de voir quelle manière dans une
action cette mouche repas aussi
simplement qu'il est venu
ainsi pendant deux ou trois minutes
salut pouvoir visualiser plusieurs de
vos rumination sous la forme de mouches
et chaque fois les lycées se poser sur
vous et repartir au fur et à mesure cela
deviendra un réflexe inconscient le
départ vous pourrez aussi après cette
séance vous amuser à imaginer votre
pensée comme une mouche à les laisser se
poser à la bcr mardi
s'amusait de voir à quel point c'est
efficace
je vous a coupé un silence pour que vous
laissiez
c'est ça
les repas dit
très bien
n'oubliez pas de recommencer chaque jour
cette séance pour entraîner votre esprit
votre cerveau j'aimerais que votre
inconscient fasse un deuxième
l'apprentissage toutes nos idées aussi
désagréable le souhaitent elles sont
présentées par notre inconscient dans
une intention positive cette attention
nous pouvons l'ignorer mais elle est
bien là quand on rumine souvent on
cherche à se protéger de gecko chaude un
risque quand on s'ouvre latéralement
bien souvent c'est pour nous rappeler
que des changements sont impératifs dans
notre vie quelque chose nous déplaît
si pour nous inviter à aller chercher
quelque chose qui nous plaît ailleurs
davantage qu'ils ne correspondent pas
j'ai demandé dans la prochaine minutes
votre esprit inconscient de vous révéler
pour chacune de ses manches
attention
positive
qui se trouve derrière compass nancy
une mouche une idée dont on accepte
l'intention positive déjà une louche qui
vous tourmentent ramoin les pensées de
tourner autour de nous que parce que
nous nous défendons parce que nous
luttons nous dépensons les plus
obsessionnel et surtout les pensées les
plus obsessionnel arrêté de ce bad
c'est une très bonne chose maintenant je
demandais à votre esprit inconscient de
vous faire vivre ceux ci au calme
tranquille
porté par la transe et ses mouches dont
vous avez compris l'intention positive
qui cette possible de se poser pour
ressortir simplement vous traverse comme
le font les sensations habituellement
les pensées quand elles ne sont pas
exceptionnelles quand ce ne sont pas des
filles
pendant 30 petites secondes simplement
mais pour sentir ressentir ce que cela
fait que de se laisser traverser par une
idée de l'accepter accepté ne veut pas
dire ne pas agir mais juste accepter se
laisser traverser jeu 30 petites
secondes pour que votre inconscient pour
fasse vivre cela
très bien
la fin de candide ce monument de la
littérature il est écrit non seulement
quelques semaines
et ma foi le gène y at il besoin de
beaucoup de temps pour s'exprimer donc
dans ce chef-d'oeuvre de voltaire lydie
à la fin et cette expression est bien
connu qu'il faut cultiver son jardin que
c'est finalement peut-être la seule
façon d'être heureux
et cette phrase un peu mystérieuse son
sens pas si évident que ça je vous
invite à le ressentir expérimenté au
travers d'une autre histoire
cette fois ci beaucoup plus proche de
notre univers l'histoire de deux
ouvriers qui travaillaient donc dans une
usine qui était marié tous deux avaient
le même nombre de points gagnés après
même ça l'argent avait à peu près les
mêmes le dire et alors que l'on entre on
était toujours malheureux se pliant aux
jours de sa vie toujours insatisfaits à
vouloir changer à vouloir que les choses
soit autrement
l'autre sont belles à vivre avec
beaucoup plus de bonheur
et si les ingrédients de leur vie de
chacune de leur vie si ces ingrédients
étaient les mêmes l'inde est malheureux
et l'autre tu es heureux l'impensé trop
une autre de penser patatras
et chacun de ses ouvriers posséder un
jardin justement un jardin ouvrier comme
il en existe encore maintenant un petit
lopin de terre souvent offert à la ville
où l'on peut finalement gardé le contact
est quelque chose d'essentiel les
saisons qui passent garder le contact
avec la terre changer d'atmosphère ne
pas assez de l'enfermement d'une usine
de l'enfermement d'un immeuble notre
enfermement mais bien voir un moment de
liberté à cultiver quelque chose
d'essentiel
chacun ses ouvriers et un lopin de terre
pas grand mais bien exposé l'un joue ce
temps l'autre et autant le jardin de
louvoyer malheureux était toujours
rempli de mauvaises herbes et donnait
peu de fruits de légumes tant nos
jardins de l'ouvrier heureux donner en
quantité fruits et légumes tous plus
succulents les uns que les autres
un jour l'ouvrier malheureux pavois
voyez heureux élus demandent à son
secret je lui dis je m'acharne retirer
toutes les mauvaises plantes jeu
j'essaie de lutter contre les insectes
les insecticides
j'essaye d'éviter que rien de mauvais
n'arrive à me plaindre
et pourtant les voilà des insectes
pullulent les jeunes y dévorent les
plantations les limaces en font de même
et mon jardin je donne presque rien vous
voyez on me dit c'est étonnant moi je ne
me préoccupe pas des mauvaises herbes
je ne me préoccupe pas d un seul je
m'occupe simplement de mes belles
plantes qui donneront des fruits des
légumes jeu lors de la boire je ne sais
pas pourquoi
finalement je n'ai pas de souci avec une
mauvaise lit avec les insectes mais je
choisis uniquement de développer de
cultiver les plantes qui marcheront et
qui me rendront heureux dans un jardinet
qu'elle est consommé une fois encore
l'histoire ne dit pas sa fin on ne sait
pas si l'ouvrier malheureux compris le
sens ce que lui disait son ami à quel
point c'est important mais finalement
une des manières les plus facile d'être
heureux c'est de cultiver ces petits
bonheurs de développer de faire grandir
s'ils pensent et agréable et c'est ce
que vous allez pouvoir expérimenter dans
un instant parce que
plus les plantes les idées les actions
des activités heureux se développent et
plus naturellement mauvaises herbes les
idées négatives 10 bases mais prenez
vous le temps de faire ce que vous aimez
borné vous le temps de penser ce qui
vous rend heureux au travail nautique
vous permet d'apprendre à développer ce
qui vous rend heureux comme quand c'est
en vous il ya simplement laisser les
autres pensées disparaître à mesure que
les pensées heureuse brême davantage de
glace il ya dans la mythologie
égyptienne une image saisissante celle
d'anubis le dieu des morts qui pèsent le
coeur des décédés sur une grande balance
et comparent leur poids et une plume
évidemment il faut que le coeur soit
plus léger que sept aps le qu'ils aient
le droit une vie heureuse
après la vie
il ya cette balle en solo si je
demandais à votre intention de le penser
que dépenser heureuse
il voudrait lui aussi pensé aussi
dépensé malheureuse lors nous allons
mettre en place de jardins dans votre
inconscient dans le premier jardin vous
avez planté trois plantes qui
correspondront un souvenir du passé
malheureux une inquiétude au présent et
une inquiétude pour votre futur
vous allez simplement ensuite refermé
les portes de ce jardin pour vous
occuper de l'autre jardin et dans ce
jardin là vous allez planter trois
plantes à nouveau nous souvenir du passé
agréable fondateur de tadoussac malgré
une joie au temps présent
petites ou grandes peu importe et un
bonheur futur que vous allez pouvoir
construire à votre rythme petit ou grand
à nouveau vous les plans très les unes
après les autres et vous les observez
règlement dire jacques une telle mesure
qu'ils grandiront vous pourrez y revivre
à nouveau ses pensées et les sentir se
fortifiait se développer en vo à mesure
qu'ils grandiront ils vous prendrez
d'abord la plante du passé et la
prennent du présent si la plante de
l'avenir elle chaque fois vous
ressentirez bien faire
pour ce travail vous prendrez autant de
temps qu'il le faut c'est pour ça que je
vous accompagne en silence et à la fin
une fois que vous aurez planter ses
trois plantes et que à la fin de tout ce
travail et nautiques
vous ressentirez une envie de bonheur il
a envie de faire quelque chose de
particulier simplement pour être heureux
d'être une simple balade embrasser
quelqu'un que vous aimez écrire un mot à
quelqu'un que vous appréciez et je vous
invitais évidemment à ne pas attendre
à saisir à saisir cette opportunité de
bonheur comme le penseur nous invite à
cueillir le jour aux carmes et dit m et
maintenant il est temps de vous laisser
en transe planter ses trois plantes
vivre leur développement ressenti à
l'envi d'un 1,5 et la fin pour sortir de
transe vous compterez de 1,5
une fois que ce travail intérieur ô
combien important a été fait je vous
laisse
cultivez votre jardin